dit on en parle avec vous bruno daroux
bonjour donc à des sanctions qui sont en
discussion à quoi peut-on s'attendre
concrètement alors écoutez les sanctions
il faut bien voir que ce serait des
sanctions avant tout économique et
ciblées il n'est pas question à ce stade
que ni les américains ni les européens
ni interviennent militairement
évidemment en cas de de pénétration des
troupes russes en ukraine alors premier
type de sanction on parle d'une
exclusion de la russie du système swift
c'est un système absolument essentiel
pour les échanges bancaires
internationaux donc là serait un impact
assez fort sur le système bancaire russe
et tout ce que ça implique bien sûr on
évoque aussi des sanctions directes et
ciblées donc contre une trentaine de
personnes environ qui sont dans
l'entourage direct de vladimir poutine
plus leurs proches ce qui pourrait être
très invalidante relie mais pour ces
personnes qui souvent des résidents
secondaires aux états unis et surtout en
europe certains mêmes vont jusqu'à dire
qu'il faudrait cibler directement les
avoirs de vladimir poutine enfin il y à
un autre type de sanctions qui est
évoquée qui est ciblé mais là
économiquement sur le fameux gazoduc
north stream 2 entre la russie et
l'allemagne le nouveau gouvernement
allemand dit effectivement qu en cas
d'invasion partielle de l'ukraine par
les troupes russes et bien il pourrait
jeu les stopper l'activité de ce gazoduc
on voit que les états unis avec cette
visite dans tony blinken a à berlin
tentent d'impliquer au maximum leurs
alliés européens alors que le chef de la
diplomatie américaine doit rencontrer
demain à genève à sergueï lavrov et son
homologue russe oui joke la diplomatie
américaine a retenu un peu les leçons de
ce qui a été fait ces derniers mois on
se souvient notamment du retrait
d'afghanistan qui avait été décidé de
manière unilatérale par les etats-unis
sans vraiment mettre dans la boucle
leurs partenaires européens sans parler
évidemment de la crise des sous marins
australiens avec la france donc là la
leçon a été apprise est retenu et puis
évidemment ça se passe quand même en
europe ce que n'ont pas cessé de répéter
les dirigeants européens puisqu'ils ont
bien vu en eux que vladimir poutine
voulait les écarter de toute discussion
sur le dossier ukrainien et privilégier
une relation directe avec washington
histoire de prestige pour la russie donc
du coup les états unis ne veulent pas
rentrer dans le piège tendu par moscou
est effectivement font grand cas de
leurs alliés européens
là c'est une réunion aujourd'hui
effectivement à berlin à l'issue de
laquelle anthony blinken doit s'exprimer
avec donc les alliés allemands français
et britanniques ce qu'on appelle parfois
le quad transatlantique donc histoire de
montrer que les grands pays européens en
tout cas ceux qui ont une diplomatie une
défense
importantes sont évidemment associé aux
discussions et évidemment au passage
aussi vérifier que tous les alliés
européens sont sur la même ligne entre
eux des gens et aussi avec les
américains par exemple je vous parlais
des sanctions concernant le système
swift donc exclure la russie des
échanges bancaires internationaux pardon
les allemands ne sont pas très
favorables de manière générale
d'ailleurs les allemands restent fermes
mais ont toujours l'héritage de ce qu'on
appelait l'ostpolitik un la houle le la
politique favorable à une solution vers
l'est à la fois être ferme avec moscou
mais ne pas rompre le dialogue et la
france n'est pas très loin de de cette
position merci beaucoup bruno daroux
pour cet éclairage